Le Café de
l'Espace des sciences avec la revue
Science Ouest,
Bonsoir.
Bonsoir à toutes et à tous,
Bienvenue au Café des sciences,
le dernier de l'année.
D'ailleurs, ce soir,
cette rencontre est organisée par l'équipe
de rédaction du magazine Science Ouest,
qui est le mensuel de l'Espace
des sciences que vous pouvez découvrir
auprès de mon collègue là bas.
Et je vous invite notamment à prendre
connaissance du tout dernier numéro
qui lui est consacré à la criminologie,
à la criminalistique.
On est allé à la rencontre
des experts en Bretagne qui qu'ils
intègrent, qui interviennent lorsqu'il
y a une enquête, quelle qu'elle soit.
Ce soir, j'ai le plaisir
d'accueillir un scientifique passionné
que j'ai rencontré
il y a quelques mois dans son laboratoire.
Stéphane de Moulis.
Bonsoir, bonsoir !
Vous êtes ingénieur de recherche.
Où est le PG alors ?
Le PG, c'est le laboratoire
de planétologie et j'ai aussi encensé ça.
Ah non, ça !
Vous êtes venu de Nantes
pour nous voir ce soir ? Voilà,
c'est pas trop long.
Je crois que vous connaissez bien
l'espace des sciences que vous êtes venu
plusieurs fois en conférence.
Donc peut être que parmi les personnes
présentes dans le public, il y en a
certains qui sont peut être déjà venus
à votre rencontre.
En tout cas,
voilà, c'est un format un peu différent.
Mais l'idée,
c'est de parler de vos recherches
et de revenir sur un dossier précédent
dans lequel on avait parlé
bien évidemment de la planète Mars.
Parce que ce soir, je vous propose,
Stéphane, cher Public, de vous embarquer
sur la planète rouge jusqu'à 19 h 30
et je pense qu'il y a beaucoup de choses
à dire et beaucoup de questions
certainement qui fourmillent.
N'hésitez pas à lever la main
si vous avez justement une question
à poser comme ça,
mon collègue vous donnera un micro
pour qu'on puisse vous entendre.
Et surtout, l'événement est enregistré,
sera disponible
en écoute sur le site internet de l'Espace
des sciences.
Donc, c'est important qu'on
puisse vous entendre pour vous répondre.
Mais vraiment, n'hésitez pas
à intervenir dans la conversation.
On est là ce soir
pour aborder pas mal de choses.
D'ailleurs, avant toute chose, Stéphane,
Je pense que ça pourrait être intéressant.
Que vous nous expliquer pourquoi
la planète rouge est si convoitée.
Qu'est ce qu'elle a de si spécial ?
Ah ben, on peut déjà faire 1 h
sur la première question en quelques mots.
Alors en quelques mots,
pourquoi on s'intéresse à Mars ?
Il y a plusieurs aspects.
En fait, on s'intéresse à cette planète
d'un point de vue scientifique.
Je vais commencer
par l'aspect scientifique.
Pour nous.
Je dis nous au sens très large
dans la communauté.
En planétologie, on essaie de savoir.
Il y a un grand fil conducteur,
c'est essayer de savoir
d'où vient la vie en fait, comment la
pourquoi on est là.
Ça peut nous amener très loin,
mais plus philosophique aussi.
Donc il faudrait plus qu'une heure.
Donc l'idée, c'est d'essayer
de trouver dans le système solaire,
donc dans les mondes qui nous entourent,
trouver les endroits
qui autres
que la Terre, pourraient éventuellement
soit abriter la vie,
soit avoir abriter la vie par le passé.
Et en fait,
si on fait le tour du système solaire,
on a commencé à faire un tour
assez exhaustif avec les sondes spatiales.
Depuis les années 60, on se rend compte
qu'il n'y a pas beaucoup d'endroits
dans le système solaire
où on est susceptible
d'avoir des conditions favorables
à l'émergence de la vie sur Terre.
On sait que la vie est apparue
dans les océans
et on sait que l'eau liquide, c'est
un élément fondamental
pour que la vie puisse se
développer et aussi perdurer.
Vous avez vu,
même ici à Nantes et à Rennes,
quand il fait 42 degrés l'été
et qu'il ne pleut pas pendant des mois,
ça va, ça finit par poser problème.
Donc l'eau liquide, c'est
un élément fondamental.
Et si on regarde dans le système solaire
ce que les sondes nous ont appris
les sondes spatiales,
c'est que sur Mercure,
la planète la plus proche du Soleil,
impossible d'avoir de l'eau en surface.
Il fait, il fait beaucoup trop chaud
sur Vénus, la planète qui est après
il fait 450 degrés en surface,
donc on ne va pas non plus
y trouver de l'eau liquide
sur terre, il y en a. Ça,
on le sait, sur la Lune, il n'y en a pas.
La planète, après, c'est Mars.
Et là, c'est intéressant
parce qu'on va sûrement en parler.
Après toutes les sondes spatiales
qui sont allés vers Mars
nous ont raconté une histoire qui montre
qu'il y a eu de l'eau liquide
en grande quantité par le passé.
Il y en a plus maintenant,
mais il y en a eu par le passé.
Donc ça pour nous, c'est
un élément fondamental.
Si on continue plus loin, au delà de Mars,
on va trouver d'autres corps
intéressants qui vont être principalement
les satellites de Jupiter et de Saturne,
et donc ce n'est pas Jupiter
et Saturne eux mêmes
puisque là c'est une grosse boule de gaz.
On ne peut pas marcher dessus,
mais les satellites, les lunes de Jupiter
et Saturne pour certaines ont probablement
de l'eau liquide, en tout cas
la lune Europe autour de Jupiter
ou la lune Encelade autour de Saturne.
Sûrement de l'eau liquide à l'intérieur
de la Lune sous une croûte de glace,
sous une banquise.
Donc ça nous fait
un deuxième écosystème potentiellement
intéressant pour trouver la vie.
Donc voilà
Mars pour répondre à la question initiale
pourquoi ça nous fascine
d'un point de vue scientifique ?
C'est parce que
peut être qu'au début,
au moment où la vie est apparue sur Terre,
il y avait
peut être les mêmes conditions sur Mars.
Et si oui, on se demande
est ce que la vie serait
aussi apparue sur Mars en même temps
qu'elle apparaissait sur Terre ?
Et si oui, jusqu'à quel stade
de développement elle aurait pu aller ?
Donc ça, c'est l'aspect purement science.
Après, il y a un aspect purement
pour le fun exploratoire pour me dire
pourquoi on veut aller
au sommet de l'Everest par exemple.
Il n'a aucun intérêt.
Vous risquez votre vie pour aller là bas,
le pôle Nord.
Ou pourquoi on est allé au fond
des dorsales océaniques ?
Pourquoi on est allé sur la Lune la mars,
C'est clairement la prochaine étape.
Parce que tous les cas
que j'ai mentionnés, on les a fait.
C'est la prochaine étape
pour les explorateurs les plus intrépides.
On aimerait bien un jour pouvoir aller là
bas, mais on n'y est pas encore.
Et justement,
on n'y est pas encore, donc,
et on n'est pas prêt d'y aller, je pense.
Alors comment on fait
comme on peut pas y mettre les pieds
et comment on fait
pour l'étudier ? Vous évoquiez les sondes.
Depuis quand déjà
on peut s'en approcher
et par quelle grâce ?
À quelles technologies ?
Alors effectivement, on a plusieurs
pour l'exploration des planètes.
On a plusieurs phases.
Je dirais que la phase, la première phase,
c'est l'observation depuis la Terre,
donc soit à l'œil nu qu'on n'a
pas d'autre solution.
Les Grecs,
les Romains avaient déjà remarqué
qu'il y avait un point rouge
qui se promenait dans le ciel.
Je ne sais pas si vous l'avez vu parmi
les milliers de personnes qui sont là
ce soir, qui a vu Mars en ce moment
dans le ciel ?
Est ce que vous pouvez lever la main
avec un seul Aïe aïe aïe,
Un seul sur au moins 2000 personnes,
ça ne va pas du tout
regarder le ciel en ce moment.
Le soir, vous allez voir,
il y a un point rouge très brillant,
c'est la planète Mars.
Et pourquoi Je vous dis qu'il faut
le regarder maintenant ? C'est parce que
c'est seulement tous
les deux ans que Mars et la Terre
sont plus proches l'un de l'autre
et donc, en ce moment, on a les meilleures
conditions pour observer Mars.
Avant, il va falloir attendre deux ans.
Et si vous êtes,
si vous avez des insomnies,
je vous conseille
de ne pas vous coucher cette nuit
ou alors de vous lever demain matin
très tôt,
vers 5 h et demie,
parce que Mars va passer derrière la Lune.
Si vous ne savez pas
quel est le plus aller vous demander,
gardez quelle direction.
C'est facile demain matin,
c'est derrière la lune.
Juste derrière, il y aura un point rouge
et c'est Mars qui va passer derrière.
Donc ce n'était pas ça la question.
Mais donc je vais revenir à la question.
Donc le premier moyen
pour observer les planètes, c'est l'oeil.
Et ça, c'est pendant pratiquement
l'Antiquité.
C'est comme ça qu'on faisait.
Ensuite, on a inventé
la lunette astronomique et le télescope.
Donc des miroirs, des lentilles.
Donc là, on arrive au début du XVIIᵉ
siècle où l'on va avoir des moyens
pour regarder de manière un peu plus
détaillée à quoi ressemblent ces planètes.
Et pour Mars,
on va avoir un moment extraordinaire
qui est à la fin du XIXᵉ siècle
où l'un des astronomes
très crédible.
A priori, on regardait dans les télescopes
assez puissants
et ils ont cru voir à la surface de Mars
des traits rectilignes, des
des choses qui avaient l'air,
des grands traits
qui avaient l'air de se connecter
les uns aux autres.
Et à l'époque,
on savait par des mesures physiques
que Mars était
probablement une planète très froide, avec
probablement très peu d'atmosphère
et probablement très peu d'eau.
Et donc, à l'époque,
une des interprétations, c'était au moment
où perçaient les grands Canal
Canal de Suez, ce canal de Panama.
Une des interprétations
des astronomes de l'époque, c'était qu'il
y avait peut être une forme
de vie intelligente, très intelligente,
qui avait résolu
les problèmes d'approvisionnement en eau
en allant la chercher au niveau
des calottes polaires et qui l'amenait
dans les régions où il y avait
des problèmes de sécheresse.
C'était une interprétation possible
et donc beaucoup d'astronomes
ont regardé
avec les télescopes Mars en détail.
Certains ont vu ces canaux,
Ces canaux étaient très rectilignes,
d'autres ont même vu
des canaux dédoublés.
Au lieu d'en voir un, ils ont envoyé deux.
Alors je ne sais pas
ce qu'ils avaient pour se réchauffer.
Vous savez qu'on fait
des observations astronomiques ?
Il fait très froid dans la Coupole.
Donc il faut combattre le froid.
Je n'ai pas l'explication de
pourquoi certains astronomes
voyaient les canaux doubles.
Ça pouvait être une explication.
Si les canaux étaient en altitude,
imaginez quelque chose en altitude.
Ah, vous pouvez avoir une ombre et voir
l'ombre au sol
et voir quelque chose en double.
Oui, en fait.
Ces observations ont ensuite
été contredites par d'autres observations
faites au début du XXᵉ siècle,
avec des télescopes un peu meilleurs
et peut être des radiateurs
dans la coupole pour éviter de
se chauffer ou de manière
qui fait trembler la vue.
Et donc on a
oublié.
C'est un pas oublié,
mais tirer un trait sur ces canaux
et sur cette vie possible sur Mars.
Mais à l'époque,
si on regarde les livres d'astrophysique,
on pensait que la vie était
quand même possible sur Mars.
Peut être pas sous forme de Martiens,
de petits hommes verts, mais peut être
sous forme de lichens, de mousse, d'algues
qui pouvaient recouvrir
le sol de Mars.
Et ça, cette idée, la durée
pratiquement jusqu'en 1950.
On trouve dans les manuels d'astrophysique
que, pour expliquer les teintes rouges
verdâtre orangé de Mars,
c'est peut être de la végétation
très très primitive, très très résistante,
qui varie au fil des saisons.
Et ensuite on arrive là
sur l'air de l'exploration spatiale
où Les premières sondes satellites
vont être envoyées vers Mars
à la fin des années
60. Dans les années 60,
on est clairement
dans le grand boom de l'exploration
avec les Russes qui envoient
le premier satellite Spoutnik, Spoutnik.
Le premier astronaute cosmonaute
Youri Gagarine et puis les Américains
qui essayent de faire pareil
et donc envoyer une sonde vers la lune
ou vers Mars ou plus loin,
c'est montrer que vous êtes
une grande puissance internationale.
Donc là, Mars va recevoir
la visite de plusieurs sondes spatiales,
beaucoup de sondes russes qui
pratiquement toutes auront été des échecs.
Aucun lien avec l'actualité en ce moment.
Mais les sondes, les sondes martiennes
russes ont pratiquement toutes passé.
Pas pratiquement toutes
se sont soldées par un échec.
Soit la sonde s'est écrasé,
soit elle n'est pas arrivée,
soit elle a explosé au décollage
et les Américains ont été plus chanceux
et ils ont réussi à mettre des sondes.
Alors la première étape
pour aller dans l'ordre
quand on envoie une sonde spatiale,
c'est déjà faire un survol,
ne serait ce que faire
un survol d'une planète.
Vous avez le temps
de prendre quelques clichés
et c'est déjà quand vous connaissez
rien de la planète, c'est déjà énorme.
Pendant combien de temps ça dure ?
Quelques heures à peine et c'est
ce qu'on a fait sur Pluton, par exemple,
la planète la plus lointaine
du système solaire.
On a fait juste un survol
après dix ans de voyage
et ça nous a appris énormément de choses.
Une première étape, c'est le survol.
Là, les première sonde qui ont survolé
Mars,
elles ont pris des photos
et en fait les photos en noir et blanc.
Ça ressemblait beaucoup à la lune
ou les gros cratères d'impact.
Donc a priori, une surface très ancienne,
peu active géologiquement.
Et les gens étaient très déçus
parce qu'on s'attendait.
On avait un peu rêvé d'une autre terre.
On s'attendait
à quelque chose de plus excitant.
Heureusement,
ces premières sondes ont été suivies
par d'autres sondes spatiales,
notamment la sonde Mariner neuf
qui s'est mise en orbite
autour de la planète.
Et là, quand vous arrivez à vous mettre
en orbite autour de la planète,
c'est bingo parce que vous avez le temps
de faire beaucoup plus de clichés
que lorsque vous avez juste un simple
survol.
Et là,
on va commencer à découvrir une planète
avec des grandes curiosités géologiques.
Un volcan énorme
qui fait 25 kilomètres de haut,
trois fois l'Everest
des Grand Canyon, gigantesque, beaucoup
plus grand que le Grand Canyon sur Terre,
des calottes polaires faites de glace,
d'eau glacée, de CO2 et de carbone.
Et on va voir
surtout des rivières asséchées,
mais des photos qui nous montrent des
des réseaux de rivières
qui montent,
qu'un liquide a coulé à la surface.
Là, c'est la révolution
et la fin des années 60.
Ensuite, on arrive dans les années 70
où là, les Américains vont poser deux
sondes qui s'appellent les sondes Viking.
Donc deux atterrisseurs
qui vont se poser en douceur sur Mars,
plus deux orbiteurs qui vont tourner
autour de Mars pendant plusieurs années.
Et là on va faire une carte
quasiment globale de la surface
et on va voir des réseaux de rivières
partout.
Pour autant, les sondes Viking,
elles, ont fait des mesures sur place
pour essayer de voir s'ils
n'avaient pas la vie sur Mars
et s'il y avait des petites bactéries
qui auraient pu se développer sur Mars.
Elles avaient des instruments faits
pour voir si
des formes de vie pouvaient se nourrir
de nutriments qui étaient apportées
par la sonde ou, si elles le respiraient,
dégageaient des gaz.
En fait, les instruments à bord de
ces sondes Viking, on en grouille.
Si je résume, il y avait trois expériences
et il y en a une
qui a dit oui à la vie, l'autre
qui a dit non, il n'y a pas la vie.
Et la troisième qui disait bon,
il y a peut être la vie.
Bref, en gros et après coup,
on s'est rendu compte que les expériences
étaient peut être pas conçues
d'une manière suffisamment
précise
ou non ambiguë pour qu'on
puisse avoir une réponse.
Bref, on a su que, en tout cas,
l'environnement était quand même
assez assez hostile et on n'a pas détecté
directement de formes de vie.
Après, pendant pratiquement 20 ans,
il ne se passe rien.
Donc là, on est au milieu des années 70,
On vient d'avoir en parallèle
les missions Apollo ou un énorme succès
des Américains qui poussent
douze hommes à la surface de la Lune.
Et pendant 20 ans,
il ne se passe rien, c'est à dire
pratiquement soit les sondes,
soit il n'y a pas de sondes spatiales,
soit les sondes qui sont prévues
se soldent par des échecs et on va ensuite
arriver de nouveau
dans une période faste en 1996
avec la première fois où on va.
Ce sont les Américains qui font ça,
vont envoyer une sonde et vont se poser
à la surface de Mars avec un petit robot
qui fait à peu près la
taille de cette table,
la moitié de cette table
et révolution, ils vont pouvoir
le déplacer depuis la terre.
Ils vont pouvoir lui envoyer des hommes
pour qu'ils puissent se déplacer
de manière autonome.
Et il va faire pendant trois mois,
à peu près quelques dizaines de mètres
autour de sa base.
Donc c'est ce qu'on appelle un rover.
Un rover, c'est un robot,
un rover en français, un astro mobile,
donc un rover
tout petit, mais fort de ce succès.
Les Américains vont concevoir
une deuxième génération de Rover.
Ça va être les Rovers Spirit, Opportunity,
beaucoup plus gros.
Ils font 180 kilos, la taille d'un homme
et eux vont être envoyés
en 2004
et vont durer pendant plusieurs années.
Ils vont travailler,
travailler et analyser deux endroits
de la surface de Mars très passionnants.
Fort de ce succès,
les Américains vont concevoir
une troisième génération de Rover,
les Rover, Curiosity et Persévérance,
qui sont posées
respectivement en 2012 et 2021.
Là, on change de braquet.
Vous imaginez un véhicule
de la taille d'un I ?
Suivez
une voiture qu'on
envoie sur Mars et qui vont
pareil, être pilotés de manière
décalée.
Mais on programme ces Rover au jour
le jour.
Un jour,
on va programmer toutes les commandes
que le rover va appliquer le lendemain.
Le lendemain, le rover,
quand le jour se lève,
il fait tout ce qu'on lui a dit de faire
et le soir, il envoie les données
sur terre, on les récolte dans les labos,
on regarde ce qu'on a reçu
et en fonction de ce qu'on voit,
on planifie la journée du lendemain.
Il me semble que vous avez des visio
très régulièrement,
tous les jours, même des visio.
On fait ça avant le visio conférence.
On travaille beaucoup
avec des collègues américains.
C'est des rovers
qui sont fabriqués par la NASA.
Mais on a de la chance en France
puisqu'on a fabriqué
des instruments
qui sont à bord de ces rovers.
Donc il y a des instruments français
à bord des deux Rover et du coup,
ça nous permet nous,
en tant que simples citoyens nantais,
de faire
partie de l'équipe scientifique
de ces Rover.
Et donc on a un accès direct à toutes les
images, toutes les données qui arrivent.
Et on participe aussi au planning,
c'est à dire qu'on va pouvoir choisir
par exemple, quelle est la cible
sur laquelle on va faire une analyse
demain par exemple.
Donc ça, c'est un côté excitant.
Et là, j'ai parlé que des rovers,
mais en parallèle des rovers.
Sur place, on a les orbiteurs des sondes
qu'on met en orbite autour de la planète
pour cartographier de manière extrêmement
précise, extrêmement détaillée,
les structures géologiques
qu'on peut voir à la surface.
On voit la géologie,
en fait la minéralogie.
Savoir
quels sont les cailloux qui sont présents.
Sachant que certains minéraux se forment
dans un contexte avec de l'eau liquide,
d'autres,
c'est qu'il ne faut pas d'eau liquide.
Certains, ça va être de l'eau
salée, d'autres avec de l'eau pas salée,
d'autres encore, ça va être de l'eau
acide, d'autres de l'eau pas acide.
Donc pour nous trouver un minéral,
ça nous raconte une histoire.
Ça va nous permettre de dire où là
aussi, il y a des argiles comme ça
avec des carbonates.
Ça veut dire que là,
il y a eu de l'eau liquide stable.
Et s'il y a des carbonates,
c'est que c'était de l'eau pas acide.
Et nous, on aime bien pour la vie.
Vous savez que la vie se développe
plutôt dans l'eau.
On n'aime pas trop l'eau acide pour la vie
standard.
Voilà donc tout ça.
Ça nous raconte une histoire
En ce moment, à l'heure où je parle,
il y a huit sondes en orbite
autour de Mars en activité.
Donc il y a des sondes américaines.
Il y a deux sondes européennes.
Il y a une sonde des Émirats arabes unis,
une sonde chinoise, une sonde indienne.
Vous imaginez ça fait du monde.
Et donc, avec toutes ces sondes
là, on a un maximum d'informations
avec les rovers au sol.
Donc on a deux rovers américains
et un rover chinois.
Et tout est partagé.
Alors tout est plus ou moins partagé,
plus ou moins OK, c'est un peu plus
partagé
du côté américain que du côté chinois.
Sans rentrer dans les détails. OK, mais.
Mais effectivement,
il y a beaucoup de partage d'informations
et donc on a un luxe d'information
qui est assez extraordinaire.
Donc je me rappelle
la bonne nouvelle, c'est
que je me rappelle plus de la question.
Mais c'est très bien, c'est passionnant.
Je pense que j'y ai répondu quand même.
Et donc en ce moment, il y a huit sondes
qui sont en orbite
autour de Mars et sur Mars.
Alors parler de Curiosity, persévérance,
qu'est ce qu'il y a ?
A l'heure actuelle, comme Rovers sur Mars
dans Qu'est ce qui alors ?
Mais sur quelles sont les grandes mesures
qui peuvent faire
alors à l'heure actuelle en activité ?
La sonde la plus ancienne en activité,
c'est Curiosity,
qui est arrivée en 2012 et dont on se sert
quasiment tous les jours depuis dix ans.
Là, on est rendu au jour je ne sais plus
combien.
3600 et quelques de planning.
Je faisais le calcul
parce qu'on a des téléconférences tous les
je ne devrais pas le dire,
surtout que c'est enregistré.
Mais en venant en conduisant, j'ai mis la
téléconférence sur mon téléphone à côté.
Ne le répéter pas.
Je n'ai pas regardé mon téléphone
et j'écoutais juste.
Mais voilà,
on a des téléconférences régulières.
Donc là, c'était la 540ᵉ téléconférence
du mercredi sur Curiosity.
Ça nous permet de savoir
qu'est ce qui a été fait dans la semaine.
Donc Curiosity, c'est 2012.
Ensuite, il y a
l'atterrissage fixe Insight
qui lui est arrivé en 2018.
Là, c'est une station fixe
sur laquelle on travaille aussi
beaucoup en France et notamment à Nantes.
J'ai beaucoup de collègues
qui travaille là dessus.
Là, c'est surtout un sismo sismomètres
très, très précis qui s'est posé sur Mars.
L'idée,
c'est de mesurer les tremblements de mars
et avec ça, d'en apprendre
plus sur l'intérieur de la planète.
Est ce qu'il y a un noyau ?
Et s'il y a un manteau, s'il
y a une croûte ?
Quelle est l'épaisseur de la croûte ?
Donc Insight est toujours en activité,
mais en fin de vie,
parce qu'il y a de la poussière
qui se dépose sur les panneaux solaires.
Et là, il y a beaucoup de poussière et donc de moins en moins d'énergie disponible
et persévérant, ce qui est
quasiment un clone de Curiosity
qui s'est posé en 2021.
Et lui, ça marche
du feu de Dieu.
Et le revers s'est posé.
Le rover chinois s'est
lui aussi posé en 2021
et il est aussi en activité,
donc à un autre endroit de mars.
Ça fait trois Rover mobiles
et une station fixe.
Il y a un petit hélicoptère aussi.
Ah oui, il en est où lui ?
Alors ça c'est génial !
Avec avec persévérance
le clone de Qriocity.
Il y avait
en fait à chaque mission,
à chaque nouvelle mission.
Les Américains font en sorte d'avoir
des instruments qui sont innovants, c'est
à dire qu'ils vont essayer de pousser,
pousser le bouchon un peu plus loin.
Ils vont essayer de faire
un démonstrateur technologique.
Donc là,
avec persévérance, il y avait accroché.
Sous le châssis du rover,
Il y avait un mini drone,
une espèce de petit petit quadricoptère,
des hélicoptères.
Et c'est tout petit.
C'est un cube tout léger, mais
avec des pales très grandes parce qu'il
y a très peu d'air en fait, sur Mars,
l'atmosphère en grande partie disparue.
Donc si vous voulez voler sur Mars,
c'est difficile. Donc
il faut que votre drone ait des hélices
qui tournent très très très vite.
Donc là, c'est un petit drone
avec des hélices
qui font plus de 2000 tours minute,
ça tourne super vite.
Et l'idée, c'était de voir
s'il était capable de voler
au moins trois
ou quatre fois sur quelques mètres.
Ça, c'était le contrat initial.
Si on arrivait à faire ça,
c'était contre un contrat rempli.
Et donc le drone a fonctionné à merveille.
Il a fait ses premiers vols et là,
on en est au 35ᵉ
vol du drone et donc ce n'était pas prévu
qui dure autant.
Mais pour nous, c'est génial
parce que le drone, lui, il est capable
de voler plusieurs centaines de mètres
en une seule fois
et donc il peut aller à l'avant du rover
par exemple, faire de la reconnaissance.
Il a des caméras, il va nous permettre
de voir des détails très fins
sur le terrain,
ce qui va nous permettre de dire Ah bah là
oui, ça serait intéressant
qu'on arrive avec le rover
dans quelques semaines sur ce coin là
ou à l'inverse, il y a des endroits
où le rover n'ira jamais.
Typiquement des champs de dunes
ou si on va avec notre rover,
on risque de s'enliser.
Avec le drone, pas de problème,
on passe au dessus, on prend les photos,
on se pose sur les dunes,
on recharge avec des panneaux solaires
et puis après on repart.
Donc ça ouvre une autre
ère de l'exploration martienne possible,
qui est une a des drones plus ambitieux.
Ce drone sur persévérance,
c'est un peu l'équivalent
du petit robot
dont je vous avais parlé en 1996.
Le robot de la taille d'une table
qui était le précurseur de Spirit
et de Curiosity et Persévérance.
Donc là, il y a actuellement
des ingénieurs qui travaillent
sur une deuxième génération de drones,
beaucoup plus gros, plus ambitieux,
avec plus d'instruments scientifiques.
Et ils devront avoir plus d'énergie
pour voler des pales
peut être plus grandes.
Mais ça a tellement bien marché que
là, dans un des objectifs de persévérance,
le dernier rover à arriver,
c'est de prélever,
prélever des échantillons,
de les mettre des petits tube à essai
fermés hermétiquement,
de déposer ses tubes à essai
dans un endroit bien connu
de tout le monde,
même des Chinois, s'ils ont envie d'aller
les chercher.
L'idée, c'est qu'on retourne les chercher
avec une mission qui sera prévue
pour 2028, donc une mission
qui irait atterrir juste à côté,
qui utiliserait des petits drones
pour venir ensuite
prendre les tubes à essai,
les ramener dans une espèce de fusée
qui sera posée avec la sonde.
On met ça dans la fusée et hop,
la fusée renvoie les tubes
à essai, les met en orbite autour de Mars
et une autre sonde qui serait fabriquée
par les Européens partirait de la Terre.
Irait chercher le petit
container en orbite autour de Mars.
Et oui, nous ramènerai ça sur terre
dans nos laboratoires.
Si tout va bien,
on en parle pour 2032 1032
directement à Nantes,
ça serait bien,
ça serait bien.
Je pense pas qu'on en aura à Nantes.
Alors l'idée, c'est que ce soit ramené
déjà dans des laboratoires extrêmement
sécurisés, l'équivalent
des laboratoires P4
pour, tout simplement
parce qu'on ne veut pas
contaminer les échantillons
avec de la vie terrestre.
Une des grandes questions,
c'est ce que la vie pourrait avoir
se développer sur Mars ou pas.
Biaisée dans les images.
Pour l'instant, on n'a pas d'évidences
qu'il y a des formes de vie,
même fossiles.
Pour autant,
on a détecté de la matière organique,
donc de la matière à base de carbone
hydrogène, oxygène, azote.
C'est à dire des choses
qui sont aussi les briques du vivant.
Mais la matière organique, ce n'est pas
forcément que le vivant qu'il a produit.
Il y a aussi des des réactions chimiques
qui peuvent en faire
de la matière organique.
Mais l'idée, c'est pouvoir ramener
ces échantillons sur terre et les passer
dans des des systèmes d'analyse
extrêmement complexes,
très lourds, très énergivores,
qu'on ne peut pas amener sur Mars,
mais qui nous permettraient
de regarder à un niveau
un niveau du nanomètre
dans ces échantillons.
S'il n'y a pas des traces
de vie fossiles
laissées dans ces roches qui sont
prélevées de manière très précautionneuse.
Donc ça, c'est l'étape d'après,
C'est vraiment pouvoir ramener
des échantillons de la planète.
Donc ça, c'est fait pour la Lune.
Les astronautes Apollo ont ramené à peu
près 400 kilos d'échantillons lunaires.
Ça nous a appris énormément de choses.
Et si vous avez des questions, là dessus,
on peut.
On pourra en parler sur Mars.
Pour l'instant, on a aucun échantillon,
à part peut être des météorites.
Vous savez, les étoiles filantes
qu'on voit dans le ciel, des fois ci,
c'est les cailloux qui font
les étoiles filantes sont assez gros
et peuvent survivre à la traversée
de l'atmosphère, tomber par terre
et dans les collections de météorites,
on a des météorites qui ont des propriétés
qui nous laissent penser que peut être,
elles ont été éjectés de la planète Mars
par des gros impact
et puis par le jeu des voilà.
En attendant
des fois des millions d'années,
ces cailloux ont fini par retomber
sur terre.
C'est possible, mais on ne sait pas d'où
ils viennent.
Donc est ce que c'est vraiment ça ?
C'est très différent
d'avoir un échantillon
quand on connaît le contexte.
Où est ce qu'il a été pris ?
Est ce que c'est dans des dépôts
sédimentaires ou des roches volcaniques ?
C'est beaucoup plus intéressant
d'avoir un échantillon bien contraint
qu'un caillou qui vient, dont
on ne sait pas où sur eux sur la planète.
Imaginez la terre
si vous avez juste un caillou de la Terre,
vous ne savez pas d'où il vient
et on vous dit ce qu'est la vie sur Terre,
ça peut être compliqué.
Donc voilà, l'idée, c'est vraiment
le grand pas en avant qu'on espère.
C'est pouvoir ramener
quelques centaines de grammes de mars
pour les analyser dans nos laboratoires.
Ça, c'est vraiment l'étape d'après.
Mais ça va être extrêmement compliqué.
Puis c'est une étape qui est
très importante pour en savoir davantage.
En fait, finalement, oui, parce qu'on
peut déployer énormément de mesures,
d'instruments d'analyse,
qu'on n'arrive pas envoyer sur place
et donc avec quelques grains
tout simplement.
On peut déjà faire énormément de choses,
énormément de choses.
Est ce qu'il y a des questions ?
Peut être pas encore.
C'est tellement passionnant qu'il
y a une question maintenant. Non,
mais j'en ai encore une.
Vous parliez tout à l'heure,
On va revenir sur Mars.
Vous vous parliez de la poussière
notamment,
et des dunes, donc j'imagine qu'il
y a beaucoup de contraintes.
En fait, pour les différents rovers,
je pense aussi à la température.
Comment ça se passe pour les technologies,
pour qu'elle puisse durer dans le temps ?
Alors ça, c'est une très bonne question.
Fait,
ça met les technologies à rude épreuve.
Parce que si je prends l'exemple de
pas du site de Curiosity
ou de persévérance,
on voit que la température
peut descendre à -90 degrés la nuit.
Elle peut remonter le jour à -10 ou zéro
degrés en été si tout va bien.
Mais il fait froid, il fait très froid,
il fait très froid chez nous.
La nuit, c'est bon,
donc il fait très froid et c'est
surtout il y a une amplitude thermique
très forte entre le jour et la nuit.
Donc moi, si je prends mon
téléphone, je le met sur Mars
en le
mettant à -90 zéro et ça
pendant une semaine.
Il ne va pas aimer.
Donc ça veut dire que quand vous faites
la conception de la sonde
et des instruments,
il faut que les instruments
soient capables de résister à ça.
Il y a beaucoup de poussière,
donc la poussière,
ça a tendance à venir se mettre partout.
Si vous avez des des joints articulés,
les joints articulés n'aiment pas trop
que la poussière
se mette dans les articulations.
Il n'y a pas de Rover qui fait le ménage,
il n'y a pas de rover qui fait le ménage.
Alors on peut même qui pourrait justement
évacuer la poussière,
un peu comme des essuie glaces.
Alors c'est une très bonne question
pour les sondes qui sont alimentées
par des panneaux solaires comme Insight.
Là, la
poussière qui se dépose sur les panneaux
solaires, c'est un gros problème.
Donc soit vous mettez un traitement anti,
donc comme on appelle ça
antistatique.
Et les poussières
qui sont un peu magnétiques sur Mars
ne vont pas trop
s'accrocher sur vos panneaux solaires.
C'est une façon de gagner un peu de temps.
Soit vous avez du vent.
Coup de chance sur Mars, c'est le cas.
Il y a les petites tornades
qui, pour Spirit et Opportunity, ont
ont décuplé leur durée de vie parce que
une petite mini tornade qui passe, ça
nettoie les panneaux solaires.
Soit il n'y a pas de vent et vous n'avez
pas de traitement antistatique.
Et là, c'est critique.
Et pour Insight, ce qui est la poussière
s'accumule, s'accumule, s'accumule.
Là, les ingénieurs ont trouvé une astuce
incroyable pour gagner quelques semaines
et ils ont pris avec un bras robotique.
Ils ont pris un peu un peu de sol,
ils le font tomber sur le panneau solaire
et quand
l'espèce de
sol tombe sur le panneau solaire,
ça fait une petite onde de choc
qui souffle un peu la poussière
autour de l'endroit où ça tombe.
Et donc, les panneaux solaires gagnent
un peu de visibilité.
Ils ont gagné quelques watts
en faisant des trucs comme ça,
mais c'est sportif et c'est
ce qui viendra à bout de la mission
dans quelques semaines, probablement
en amenant les Chinois ou sur leur rover.
Si je ne dis pas de bêtises.
Un système où les panneaux solaires
peuvent être remontés à la verticale
et ça c'est pas mal.
Si vous mettez les trucs à la verticale
puis vont vibrer un peu
au bien,
au moins les gros grains vont tomber.
Donc c'est une façon de gagner
un peu de temps et mettre un essuie glace.
Le problème, c'est que
un essuie glace, si vous avez
du sable sur vos panneaux solaires,
vous allez tout rayer
et je ne crois pas que ce soit très bon
pour l'efficacité.
Donc tout ça, il faut le prendre en compte
et ce qui est intéressant, c'est qu'on
va être amené à faire des développements
méthodologiques,
instrumentaux,
de malade.
Finalement, pour faire face aux conditions
extrêmes dans lesquelles on se trouve.
Parce que quand, par exemple Inside,
quand il a été posé avant,
on ne peut pas anticiper
cette accumulation de poussière
finalement, puisque c'est lié au vent.
Est ce que la zone choisie
et on sait qu'il va y en avoir beaucoup
ou pas beaucoup ?
On a.
On a des idées.
On a des modèles atmosphériques.
C'est pas assez de choses.
Donc on on a pas mal de choses
qui nous permettent d'estimer que,
par exemple, Insight, on savait qu'on
pourrait s'en servir au moins deux ans.
Voilà donc la mission nominale
c'est on fait deux ans de manip.
Si on survit les deux ans,
on considère qu'on a rempli le contrat.
Si on fait plus, tant mieux.
Mais c'est du bénef
et c'est ce qui se passe.
Et souvent c'est ce qui se passe. Et
là, on
parlait des sondes en orbite,
donc on en France.
On a aussi la chance de travailler
sur une mission qui s'appelle
Mars Express,
qui est la première sonde européenne
à arriver en orbite autour de Mars.
Et là, c'est des collègues de l'Institut
d'astrophysique spatiale à Orsay
qui ont fabriqué une caméra infrarouge
qui est à bord.
Cette sonde,
elle est arrivée en fin 2003, à Noël 2003
et elle devait durer deux ans.
Et puis on s'en sert encore 20 ans après.
Il y a toujours
encore assez de carburant à l'intérieur
pour continuer à prendre des images.
Alors il y a des instruments qui marchent
moins bien, d'autres qui marchent plus,
mais il y a d'autres
qui continuent à bien fonctionner.
Et donc, 20 ans après,
on en est encore à faire tourner le truc.
C'est un bon retour sur l'investissement.
Pour le coup,
si vous me trouvé un téléphone qui marche
20 ans après que vous l'ayez acheté,
en général, l'obsolescence programmée,
ce n'est pas pour nous.
On fait en sorte que le truc qui
marche bien,
ça pose des problèmes
parce que les agences spatiales
sont obligées de mettre des crédits
pour que les ingénieurs
fassent tourner les sondes.
Donc ce n'est pas gratuit
d'entretenir une sonde
au delà de sa durée de vie initiale.
Donc à certains qui des fois
ton truc là ce serait quand même
bien que ça se termine,
mais en même temps
c'est quand même dommage.
Vous avez imaginé
Curiosity qui roule depuis 2012 ?
Vous avez une mission extraordinaire
qui est sur Mars, qui marche bien,
Vous n'avez pas coupé le contact
quand même ?
Ce serait quand même dommage.
Donc on prolonge la mission
et puis on se débrouille, on trouve,
on essaye d'optimiser aussi
la façon de faire tourner les sondes
pour qu'il y ait besoin de moins de monde.
Et ça, ça se travaille.
Et est ce qu'il
peut y avoir des pannes par exemple ?
Alors oui, des pannes,
il est arrivé, il y en a régulièrement.
Sur Curiosity par exemple, on a,
on a eu des pannes
où l'ordinateur de bord s'est mis.
Vous savez, les écrans bleus Windows,
ça arrive sur les sondes aussi.
Bon, la bonne nouvelle,
c'est que quand les ingénieurs
ont conçu le rover, ils ont fait en sorte
que tous les systèmes vitaux
soient faits en double
moteur de bord. C'est malin.
Si vous avez
une panne de l'ordinateur de bord,
automatiquement il bascule
sur l'ordinateur de secours.
Et là,
les ingénieurs se mettent autour
d'une table.
On reçoit des données de diagnostic,
on regarde ce qui se passe
et dans le cas de curiosité,
ils ont été capables
d'identifier un problème
dans la mémoire de bord
la mémoire RAM qui avait pris un PET
et ils ont fait un système de.
C'est comme les mises à jour
Windows, un patch qui a été téléchargé
à bord du Robert du rover
et qui a permis de réparer
le problème initial.
Et donc on a pu rebasculer
sur l'ordinateur principal
remis à jour
jusqu'à ce qu'il y ait une nouvelle panne.
Donc il y a eu ce problème là sur ChemCam,
l'instrument
lequel on travaille
fabriqué par nos collègues à Toulouse.
ChemCam, c'est un système de laser,
donc on tire avec un laser sur les roches,
on focalise ce laser et on vaporise
une petite partie de la roche.
C'est un peu Star Wars, donc on fait
un tout petit trou dans la roche
et on analyse par spectroscopie
la lumière émise au moment du tir laser.
Les Curiosity sur Curiosity
et il y a le même sur persévérance
en faisant ça
et on fait une image très précise
de l'endroit où on a tiré avant le laser
et après le laser pour voir la différence.
Et en faisant ça,
on est capable de déterminer sans bouger
le rover, la composition des atomes
dans les roches qui sont à côté.
Donc c'est très, très pratique.
Le problème, c'est que pour faire la mise
au point des images,
il y a une diode
laser à bord sur l'instrument
qui était prévu pour fonctionner deux ans
à peu près.
Et en fait, la diode est tombée en panne.
Alors là, on se retrouve avec un appareil
photo qui n'a plus d'autofocus.
Alors faire des photos floues,
ça va bien, mais
ça ne sert pas à grand chose.
Donc là, gros problème.
Et bien il a fallu plusieurs mois,
mais on a réussi
en mettant en place un nouveau système
pour faire la mise au point.
On a fait un système qui prend
une quinzaine d'images avec des focus
différents, comme si vous tourniez
votre bague d'appareil photo.
Ça prend une quinzaine d'images.
Et puis on a chargé
dans la mémoire de bord
un nouveau logiciel qui calcule
automatiquement quelle est l'image
la plus nette
et qui renvoie sur Terre
uniquement l'image la plus nette.
Donc en faisant ça,
ce système là, ça restauré
les capacités d'autofocus de l'instrument.
Donc on voyait de nouveau nets
et ça a amélioré l'instrument.
Parce que avant de faire ça, l'instrument
n'était pas
capable
de faire des des images à l'infini.
Il ne pouvait pas focaliser
parce qu'il fallait envoyer une diode,
éclairer l'infini.
Avec la diode, ça ne marchait pas.
Donc on ne pouvait pas faire des images
nettes à l'infini avec un autofocus.
Et après la panne, une fois réparé,
l'instrument marchait mieux qu'avant.
Donc il y a plein d'histoires
comme ça. De panne
Sur Curiosity, on
a une foreuse,
donc une perceuse à percussion.
Imaginez au bout du bras
et un bras robotique qui fait 80 kilos.
Et au bout du bras, il y a une perceuse
à percussion qui fait un petit trou de.
C'est à peine un cm de diamètre sur six cm
avec un système de percussion.
C'est pour prélever ou en prélever
les échantillons prélevés.
35 échantillons.
Depuis l'arrivée de curieux utilisés,
on les met dans des fours d'analyse.
On analyse
si on fait plein de trucs avec ça.
Ce système est tombé en panne lui aussi.
Et en fait, il y a un système avec deux
deux tiges
qui viennent se positionner sur le sol.
Et puis le foret est au milieu.
Le foreign, j'ai du mal à le faire
avec une seule main.
Bien. J'ai quand même y arriver.
Hop hop !
C'est pas grave, c'est pas filmé,
c'est l'avantage.
Donc là il y a les deux trucs comme ça
et il y a la mèche qui vient au milieu
une fois que le main
est stabilisée par les deux,
les deux trucs et ça, ça marchait plus,
notamment la mèche.
On n'arrivait plus à la rentrée à sortir
à cause d'un court circuit.
Donc les ingénieurs ont trouvé une astuce
pour réussir à sortir la mèche
et ils ont trouvé une astuce
pour poser le bras sans qu'il
y ait de contact avec le sol.
Avec les deux stabilisateurs.
Et donc c'est un peu comme si vous faisiez
un trou avec votre perceuse,
mais sans toucher.
Vous savez souvent Enfin, moi, je fais ça
si je fais un trou dans une dent du bois
avec ma main gauche,
je tiens le bois et avec ma main droite,
mais la perceuse dessus, je fais mon trou.
Là, ils ont fait un système
sans la main gauche qui tient le bois,
c'est à dire à distance.
On tient la perceuse
vraiment à bout de bras comme ça,
et le système va réussir
sans la percussion, à faire un trou.
Ça a pris je ne sais plus combien.
Six mois,
huit mois, neuf mois avec des tests
faits en laboratoire
avec une doublure du rover
et au bout de huit mois,
ils ont réussi à restaurer.
Enfin,
remettre en état le système de percussion
et on est reparti
pour des années de forage sur Mars.
Donc il y a plein d'exemples comme ça
où on arrive à restaurer
une partie des sondes.
Ça ne marche pas à tous les coups.
Est ce qu'il y
une anecdote, vous
qui vous a particulièrement marqué
ou plusieurs ?
Je ne sais pas, mais celle là,
c'est dont je viens de parler.
J'ai eu de bonnes surprises,
des bonnes surprises.
C'est pour revenir sur les anecdotes liées
à l'instrument
français, comme Cam
donc qui me calme.
Je vous disais c'est un laser
qui tire sur les roches et le laser
est secondé par une caméra caméra noir
et blanc
qui avait juste pour vocation
à regarder le sol
à quelques mètres du rover
pour voir à l'endroit
où on tire avec le laser.
Donc avant le tir laser et après le tir
à laser, voir les changements.
La caméra, elle, n'a
pas été faite pour autre chose que ça.
Donc quand les ingénieurs l'ont conçu,
les ingénieurs notamment
du CNET à Toulouse,
et bien ils avaient construit un système
où la focalisation de la caméra
était faite à quelques mètres du rover
et ce n'était pas prévu qu'on pointe
la caméra à l'horizon, par exemple.
Donc le système qui fait la mise
au point de la caméra, c'est un système
avec un miroir sur une vis sans fin,
comme qu'on éloigne, on rapproche.
Suivant.
Quand vous voulez faire une photo
nette à quelques mètres de vous
ou une photo
nette à dix mètres ou 100 mètres.
Et on a mis pratiquement un an.
Donc la curiosité de Curiosity
est arrivée en août 2012.
Donc l'instrument a marché.
Donner ses premières images,
ça marchait super bien.
Puis petit à petit,
on s'est dit C'est quand même dommage.
La caméra marche bien
et je trouve que c'est le téléobjectif
le plus puissant de Curiosity.
Vous imaginez comme à Roland-Garros ?
Vous savez, les moi ce qui me fait rêver
les photographes ont des objectifs
gros comme ça,
c'est à peu près la même focale.
Donc cet instrument, ça permet de faire
des photos avec une focale énorme,
donc potentiellement de voir très loin.
Mais elle n'était pas conçue pour ça.
Le problème, c'est que pour faire la mise
au point à l'infini,
il fallait reculer le miroir de mise
au point et le miroir.
Il était sur une vis sans fin,
sans butée derrière.
Donc ça veut dire que si vous reculez
votre miroir sur la vis sans fin,
mais que vous allez au delà de la butée,
votre miroir y tombe
et il n'y a personne venir
remettre le miroir sur.
Donc au début de la mission,
c'était vraiment rigolo.
On a fait des images.
Alors au début de mettre trois mètres,
six mètres, dix mètres,
puis on prend un risque.
C'est pas prévu pour,
mais on fait une image où on focalise.
À 20 mètres, ça marche super.
Puis quelques semaines après,
allez donc au fait à 100 mètres.
Génial ça dingue !
Et puis il a plus d'autofocus,
donc il faut réfléchir
comment on fait pour faire
la mise au point. Mais ça marchait bien.
Et puis ça a pris un an
pour obtenir la première image
faite à l'infini
et les premières images qui étaient super,
qui étaient trois fois
plus détaillées que les caméras prévues
pour observer à l'infini.
Et donc, à partir de là,
cet instrument qui n'était pas prévu
pour ça,
est devenu un imageur
qu'on utilise tous les jours en ce moment.
Quand on planifie les opérations
avec Curiosity
tous les jours, on fait des mosaïques
à l'infini avec cette caméra
qui n'était pas prévue ça, et parce qu'on
voit des détails très, très fins.
Donc c'est de vous apporter
énormément de données
qui n'était pas prévu
mais qui sont des données.
Ce n'était pas prévu.
Ça nous permet de voir
si je fais une analogie,
alors ça ne va pas marcher ici.
C'est dire combien de kilomètres ?
Saint-Malo 60 ce 73 ?
Parfait. Et bien c'est comme ça.
C'est comme si avec cet instrument,
c'est comme si d'ici,
si vous allez vous monter sur vous avez vu
la partie la plus haute.
Je ne sais pas
quelle est la tour la plus haute à Rennes.
La tour des Horizons peut être.
Voilà, vous vous mettez
sur un point de vue assez haut,
vous regardez à Saint-Malo et en fait,
vous allez être capable de voir
des des voitures
ou les vitres des voitures dans la rue
à Saint-Malo.
Avec ce type de téléobjectif, ça nous permet de voir des détails extrêmement fins.
Et sur Mars,
on a vu, on a regardé les remparts
du cratère qui sont à 65 kilomètres
du revers et on voit des blocs
qui font à peine quelques mètres,
qui dégringolent
dans des glissements de terrain.
Donc, on voit des choses
extrêmement précises avec cet instrument
qui, encore une fois,
n'était pas prévu pour ça au départ.
Ça, c'est un peu le côté
qu'on essaie de faire un maximum de choses
avec les moyens qu'on a.
Et des fois,
on arrive à aller au delà de ce qu'on
avait conçu et imaginé au départ.
Alors, il y a les images.
Vous parlez des échantillons tout à l'air,
mais il me semble qu'il
y a eu des sons aussi.
Ah oui, qu'est ce qu'on entend sur Mars
alors ?
Le son, ça, c'est encore
une grande première qui est qui est due.
Cette fois, c'est sur l'instrument
Super Cam qui est toujours piloté
par nos collègues à Toulouse
mais fabriqué par nos collègues
à Toulouse.
Avec, il y a des collaborations
un peu partout en France.
Donc sur Super Cam,
il y a encore une fois un laser
pour analyser la composition des roches.
Mais il y avait en plus
la possibilité
d'enregistrer le son sur Mars
et c'est la première fois
qu'on avait un micro qui marche sur Mars.
Ça avait déjà été essayé
sur des missions précédentes, mais
l'instrument n'avait pas marché.
Donc, pour la première fois,
on a eu la mesure du son.
Et c'est assez émouvant
parce qu'on n'entend pas grand chose.
Si vous prenez
les enregistrements sonores, on en a plus.
Je crois qu'on est rendu à treize ou 14 h
d'enregistrement.
Oui, comme on va. Écoutez, comme ça,
faut prendre un bon
casque et vous allez entendre le vent.
Donc le vent très très lointain.
Vous allez entendre les bruits du rover.
Si le rover roule sur des cailloux,
vous entendez des espèces de cliquetis.
C'est les roues,
les roues qui écrasent les cailloux.
Vous allez entendre les tirs du laser,
ça fait des tac tac, tac, tac, tac tac
quand on tire au laser sur les roches.
Mais le son est très déformé
par rapport à la terre.
Ça fait comme il y a très peu d'air.
L'air est très raréfié.
Sur Mars,
c'est à peu près six bars de pression,
donc c'est à peu près 150 fois
moins que la pression qu'on a sur terre.
C'est pire
que si vous alliez au sommet de l'Everest.
Donc il y a très peu d'air,
donc la propagation du son
est très différente de celle
qu'on a sur terre.
Et ce qui est très surprenant,
c'est que le son, on s'est rendu compte
que les aigus se propagent pas
à la même vitesse que les graves.
Donc on a pu écouter les graves
avec les pales de l'hélicoptère notamment,
qui on voit un son assez grave.
Donc on a pu mesurer le temps de vol
et on s'est rendu compte
que la vitesse du son
avait une certaine valeur.
Et quand on écoute
des aigus avec les tirs lasers,
eh bien on voit que la vitesse du son,
ce n'est pas la même.
Donc si vous allez écouter une symphonie
sur Mars, ça risque d'être bizarre
parce que bon, déjà vous n'allez pas,
c'est un autre style à mon truc.
Parce que si vous enlevez votre casque,
vous allez pas
survivre
au delà de quelques dizaines de secondes.
Donc vous n'avez pas profiter du son
en direct pendant très longtemps.
Et si vous voulez écouter le son,
vous aurez forcément un casque et le cas
le son sera retransmis dans votre casque.
Donc du coup, il ne passera pas par l'air,
l'air ambiant.
Bon, mais en tout cas, c'est c'est
une propriété assez extraordinaire.
Et ce qui n'était pas prévu,
c'est qu'avec les mesures du son,
on allait pouvoir faire énormément
de choses.
En physique notamment,
on peut mesurer la dureté des roches.
Le son n'est pas le même quand.
Vous tapez au laser sur une roche dure
ou sur une roche tendre.
Donc on peut remonter
à des propriétés physiques des roches.
Avec l'enregistrement du son,
on peut remonter à la température,
à la pression même des infos sur le vent,
la direction du vent.
Donc les micros, c'est une mine d'or
pour les physiciens.
C'est des mesures
qu'on n'avait eu auparavant
et qui nous apprennent
énormément de choses.
Et ça peut permettre, j'imagine aussi
de confirmer des choses que vous avez
peut être observées et ça permet de.
Oui, il y a des stations météo
sur sur Curiosity, sur persévérance
et donc le micro apporte des infos
très complémentaires
à ce que la station météo,
la station météo peut mesurer.
Donc, en termes
de physique et de résultats
scientifiques, il y a énormément de choses
à sortir de ces manips.
Plus le côté qui fait rêver,
le côté communication
vers le grand public que vous.
Je vous dis vous prenez un bon casque,
vous fermez les yeux,
vous prenez un beau panorama martien.
Si vous avez de la chance,
vous avez une grande télé
et vous mettez un beau panorama martien
sur cette grande télé.
Vous vous concentrez là dessus.
Vous êtes transporté à 60 millions
de kilomètres de la Terre et
ça peut être une expérience intéressante.
Est ce qu'il y a des questions ?
N'hésitez pas à
On va les prendre
les unes après les autres.
Bonsoir monsieur, bonsoir,
juste par rapport au son,
j'ai une question.
Elle va peut être
iconoclaste, mais
au niveau des données qui sont produites
alors que ce soit le son et cetera
c'est en open source, c'est à dire
que tout le monde peut avoir accès
ou seuls les labos ou certains labos
ont accès à l'information.
C'est un premier niveau de questions
parce que le deuxième, je dis si c'est
accessible à tout le monde.
Regarde les Transmusicales en ce moment,
histoire de on peut le récupérer
et faire un concert avec.
Donc c'est
est ce que c'est ouvert à tous ?
La donnée produite ?
C'est une très bonne question et
la NASA a une politique
qui est très très ouverte
sur la distribution des données
sur les images, par exemple les images.
Alors ce sont les images brutes, les JPG,
elles sont mises en ligne
quasiment dès qu'elles arrivent sur terre.
Donc le grand public
peut avoir accès comme moi
quasiment
instantanément aux images qui arrivent
et les enregistrements
des différents instruments, c'est pareil.
Il y a une politique d'archivage
des données qui est faite
pour qu'il y ait un maximum de gens
qui puissent les utiliser.
Alors, ce que l'on fait souvent
dans notre domaine scientifique,
c'est
qu'on peut quand même garder une période.
On appelle ça une période propriétaire
ou pendant six mois.
C'est l'équipe
qui a développé l'instrument
va avoir la primauté de ces données.
C'est un peu sous embargo
finalement, sous embargo,
parce que cet instrument, pour certains,
c'est quinze ans de leur vie
qu'ils ont passé à concevoir l'instrument.
Donc effectivement, si vous passez
quinze ans de votre vie à fabriquer
l'instrument, puis au jour le jour
ou toute votre temps, à faire marcher
un instrument que vous n'avez pas le temps
d'analyser les données,
ça serait frustrant que ce soit
mis en ligne, que tout soit mis en ligne
direct et que l'équipe concurrente,
qui n'a rien fait, publie l'article.
Voilà, avant de communiquer.
J'imagine que c'est important,
mais vous, vous n'avez
plus vos résultats scientifiques,
donc il y a une espèce de compromis
trouvé pour que les équipes scientifiques
et la primauté des données
quand elles arrivent,
mais au bout d'un temps qui est un temps
défini à l'avance,
c'est à peu près six mois sur les données.
Les données doivent être archivées,
mis à disposition de tout le monde
sur un site d'archivage qui est à la NASA.
Donc ça marche assez bien, très bien même.
Après, sur le revers chinois
par exemple, je ne sais pas où
je peux trouver les données.
Toutes les agences n'ont pas
les mêmes politiques de distribution.
l'Agence spatiale européenne,
ça fonctionne un peu différemment.
On va trouver les données aussi,
mais il y a plus de latitude
qui est laissée
à chaque responsable d'instruments
pour dire si oui ou non
il veut les partager.
Donc des fois,
vous devez attendre
beaucoup plus longtemps,
voire à plusieurs années,
pour trouver un jeu
de données particulier.
Parce que ce n'était pas contractuel
avec l'Agence spatiale européenne.
Que ce soit relâché alors que côté NASA,
c'est vraiment contractuel.
Donc là, si on veut écouter les 14 h,
alors si vous voulez écouter du son
sur Mars, vous allez en trouver plein,
vous allez en trouver plein. Et
donc c'est
assez facile de vivre l'aventure.
Et ce qui est génial,
c'est qu'il y a des astronomes amateurs
qui passent leur soir week end en vacances
à fouiller dans ces données
et notamment dans la communauté.
Autour des images,
il y a des ou des passionnés
d'images qui récupèrent les images brutes
et qui vont nettoyer ces images,
les assembler, faire des panoramas,
rajouter un ciel
et éventuellement rajouter
un petit astronaute
pour publier ça sur Flickr ou sur
et vous trouver des tonnes de
de mosaïques, d'images
qui sont magnifiques et qui sont faites
par la communauté amateur.
Bon, c'est souvent des amateurs éclairés,
mais voilà, j'ai qui est à Vannes, qui
n'est pas très loin, qui s'appelle Thomas.
Après, qui a fait sa thèse en plein été
et tout ça, Il est prof de physique avant,
mais il passe un temps fou à faire tout ça
et il fait un boulot extraordinaire.
Et c'est grâce au fait que ces données
sont effectivement son public
pour une grande partie.
Il y a une deuxième question dans ça.
Bonjour, c'est concernant.
Étant donné qu'il
y a très peu d'atmosphère sur Mars,
est ce que les rayons solaires
peuvent provoquer
des problèmes sur l'électronique
ou l'informatique du rover ?
Oui, alors très peu d'atmosphère,
Ça pose problème parce que
c'est même pire que ça.
Il y a peu d'atmosphère et il n'y a pas de
pas de champ magnétique.
Donc vous cumulez deux problèmes
et vous parlez des instruments.
Donc les instruments, c'est
une chose, l'homme, c'est autre chose.
On ne pas aborder le sujet encore,
mais on pourra en parler
si vous envoyez un homme sur Mars.
Déjà, je vous ai dit il n'y a pas
d'erreur, donc il n'y a pas de pression.
Donc déjà, s'il n'a pas de scaphandre et
son sang va se mettre à bouillir,
il va lui arriver des problèmes.
Mais quand
bien même si vous arrivez sur Mars,
la surface est bombardée
par des rayonnements ultraviolets
parce que nous, sur Terre,
il y a la couche d'ozone qui nous protège.
Sur Mars, y a pas ça.
Donc la surface bombardée
par des rayonnements ultraviolets.
Mais en plus il n'y a pas de champ
magnétique.
Nous, la terre, il y a le champ magnétique
qui nous protège.
Vous savez, les aurores boréales,
les fameuses aurores,
c'est draperie verdâtre
qu'on voit au niveau des pôles.
Ça, c'est des particules chargées
émises par le soleil, les galaxies
qui sont déviées par le champ magnétique
de la Terre, qui vont vers les pôles.
Au lieu de nous arriver
toutes en direct sur Mars, on pense qu'il
y a eu un champ magnétique
au début de l'histoire de la planète.
Ça, c'est intéressant
parce que pour l'émergence de la vie,
c'était un élément favorable.
Mais comme Mars est deux fois plus petite
que la Terre, elle s'est refroidie
plus vite que la Terre et du coup,
elle a perdu son moteur.
Finalement,
qui était à l'origine du champ magnétique,
peut être au bout de 500 millions
d'années.
1 milliard d'années
donc, n'ayant plus de champ magnétique,
eh bien, la surface, elle, est bombardée
par des particules chargées,
très énergétiques, qui vont elles aussi
abîmer vos instruments.
Et s'il y a de la vie bien pareil, la vie
va prendre, va prendre cher avec ça.
Donc une des missions de Curiosity, c'est
avec un instrument qui s'appelle RAD,
un instrument
qui a été fait par les Russes,
il me semble bien.
C'est dans le monde d'avant.
Donc cet instrument servait à mesurer,
mais il sert toujours.
Il sert à mesurer
justement le taux de radiation
que le rover reçoit au jour le jour.
L'idée,
c'est si un jour on veut envoyer un homme,
et ben
il va falloir probablement le protéger
pour ne pas qu'il
soit irradié par ces particules.
Et Curiosity a mesuré que sur la durée
d'une mission martienne
typique qui est de deux ans
selon nos scénarios actuels,
eh bien, l'astronome de l'astronome,
l'astronaute recevrait
une dose de radiations équivalente
à peu près à ce que l'on tolère
pour une carrière entière d'astronaute.
Donc, en gros,
vous griller toutes vos cartouches
en faisant un aller retour sur Mars
qui dure à peu près deux ans
et sachant que c'est à peu
près dix fois moins de risques
que si vous fumez.
Je dis ça si ma fille un jour écoute
cette émission
qui apparemment est enregistrée.
Donc si vous fumez,
vous avez à peu près dix fois
plus de chances de développer un cancer
que si vous faites un aller retour vers
Mars, vous allez être en partie irradié.
Donc ce qui est intéressant, c'est
que ces mesures de Curiosity
semblent dire que oui, les radiations,
c'est un problème dont il faut s'occuper.
Mais le niveau, pas à un niveau
trop critique
pour faire en sorte
que ce ne soit pas possible.
Maintenant, c'est
un problème pour les instruments aussi.
On parlait d'instruments vont rester
dix ans à fonctionner sur Mars.
L'électronique n'aime pas trop
que des particules très énergétiques
viennent, viennent en collision.
Donc des fois, on a le robot qui se met.
On appelle ça le mode.
Voilà,
il se passe quelque chose de pas normal,
le robot à la mesure qui est un truc
pas normal, il se met en mode.
C'est comme quand vous tombez
dans les pommes, vous savez.
Donc en mode
safe mode, je trouve pas la traduction,
mais en mode de sauvegarde c'est NBA
stand by.
Voilà, c'est une blague
et il envoie des infos à la terre,
des infos minimales sur son état
pour dire qu'il y a un truc qui ne va pas,
mais ma température et de temps,
mon énergie et de temps,
mon attitude est comme ça.
Et depuis la terre, on regarde ces données
et on voit si c'est critique ou pas.
Des fois, c'est le rover
qui a commencé à grimper sur une pente
un peu trop élevée, trop trop trop forte
et qui a commencé à patiner.
Donc ça, on n'aime pas trop.
Ils s'arrêtent, ils envoient l'info
et à ce moment là, les ingénieurs
responsables du déplacement vont essayer
de le faire partir en marche arrière,
aller sur un endroit moins dangereux.
Donc on essaie de prendre en compte
tout ça.
La mémoire de bord, elle a pris.
Il y a des parties de la mémoire RAM
qui ne marche plus.
Et ça, c'est probablement des effets
du rayonnement des de l'environnement.
Et donc les ingénieurs
ont développé des astuces.
D'ailleurs,
on doit faire régulièrement des mises
à jour du système du logiciel de bord.
Les astuces pour ne plus utiliser
cette partie de la mémoire de bord.
Il y a d'autres problèmes.
Il y a le bras articulé qui a des bas,
des joints qui sont un peu comme moi.
On entend pas ça très,
mais ça
craque aussi quand on déplace le bras.
Et voilà, il y a des
du vieillissement qui est parfois aussi
commence à être un peu critique.
Il y a les roues de Curiosity
qui ont des trous
de plus en plus gros
parce que les cailloux sont très acérés,
sont polis par le vent taillé en pointe
et ça fait des trous dans les roues.
Donc bon,
on pense qu'on peut encore rouler,
mais il ne faudrait pas que ça
continue trop.
Trop longtemps quand même. On a essayé.
Alors il nous reste une minute
donc je vais poser la question
si un jour c'est
un jour on peut aller sur Mars,
est ce que ce serait
pour faire de la science ?
Est ce qu'il y a une volonté aussi
scientifique ?
Pas forcément.
Ou c'est plus pour rêver, pour explorer
les deux.
Vous avez la réponse bien sur les deux,
mais en général
je pense que ce sera comme la lune.
Mon Point de vue, c'est que si on y va
enfin, si on envoie un homme
ou une femme sur Mars,
ce sera avant tout l'exploration, le côté.
Je suis une grande puissance et ou alors
on est, on est une grande puissance.
Tous ensemble et comme en collaborant,
collaborent ensemble, on
on va faire un truc extraordinaire.
On va aller là bas essayer.
Et nous, les scientifiques,
on va être forcément
très opportunistes
et on va dire voilà ce qui se passe.
Un truc que moi je propose
que vous appreniez cet instrument.
Et puis vous faites quelques mesures
et puis voilà.
Donc je pense qu'on en profitera
pour faire de la science.
Si on prend l'exemple des missions Apollo,
on a envoyé onze pilotes d'essai
sur la Lune lors des missions
Apollo et un scientifique,
le géologue Harrison Schmitt,
qui est toujours actif.
Et donc c'était d'abord
le côté exploration
et puis le côté course entre les Russes
et les Américains qui était le moteur.
Cela dit, on a fait énormément de sciences
avec les 400 kilos
des échantillons qui ont été ramenés.
On a fait encore.
On travaille encore sur ces échantillons
qui sont qui sont très précieux.
Donc la science, ça vient avec et
je dirais que c'est dans un cas comme ça.
C'est un peu les deux.
Si on retourne sur la Lune, là
dans les années qui viennent,
c'est certes on va faire de la science,
mais je suis à peu près convaincu
que c'est
parce que les Chinois ont dit qu'ils
allaient envoyer un Chinois sur la lune
et que du coup,
ça fait penser aux Américains
que non, C'est eux qui sont les premiers
à aller sur la lune, donc c'est eux
les premiers qui vont y retourner
et donc ça a recréé une émulation
et on se dit si
on y retourne,
ben allez, on en profitera aussi
pour faire de la science
et développer des nouveaux instruments.
Et vous m'aviez dit il y a une minute
et seulement qui est resté
et que si je continue à parler,
je vais dépasser 20 minutes.
Donc voilà, va va.
Une qu'a je vous remercie beaucoup,
vous remercie, cher Public
d'avoir été présence avec ces cours.
1 h, mais c'est passionnant
et je pense qu'on a bien voyagé.
Merci Stéphane
pour toutes ces explications.
Nous, on se retrouve au mois de janvier.
Si bien sûr, vous voulez être présent,
on parlera cette fois,
ce sera le 11 janvier.
Mercredi onze, pour parler de notre santé.
Avec une grande question comment
le réchauffement climatique peut l'impact
et comment il peut la mettre en péril ?
Voilà.
D'ici là, en tout cas,
je vous souhaite à tous
et à tous un très beau mois de décembre,
de belles fêtes de fin d'année.
Je remercie aussi l'équipe du café pour
son accueil, mes collègues, la technique.
Et puis encore une fois, merci Stéphane
pour pour ce soir, à bientôt.
Merci beaucoup.